- So we've all dealt with ups and downs.
And you posted this letter
that you wrote to yourself
a while ago, giving yourself life advice.
I love this.
Where were you in life
when you wrote this?
Like, were you hugely successful already?
Where you, like, what was happening?
- I think I was, I was working.
I was like, boy, my penmanship's
the nuns would be furious.
I was working. But I think, you know,
it's like at every stage
you're always like,
what am I doing? What
am you always kind of,
I think through my 30's, I was still like,
what am I doing?
Like you always, I think your
expectations are unrealistic
and it's not until you
kind of get past that,
that you look back and
you go, oh, that was okay.
That was a good, like,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- I was fine then I
just didn't know it yet.
So I was like, I want
to stop doing that thing
of realizing 5 years after the fact
that I was really doing okay.
And I should have just
appreciated the moment.
So I kind of wrote this to be like,
I want to look at myself now
and go through all of those moments
and just be like, we're
so hard on ourselves.
I think,
- Oh my gosh, yeah.
- Just across the board and it's like,
it's okay to just be
like, it's pretty good.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- It's pretty good.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah. I agree. I agree.
Well, I love your advice yourself.
Would you talk us through
some of these wise words?
I love this one first in 10 years,
you will not remember his name.
(laughing)
(audience clapping)
I love that!
- It's true
- Cause it is, it seems
so huge in the moment.
- I know that I was thinking about
just when you think that's
it, that's it, that's the one.
And I'm like, and I was trying
to go back and I was like,
okay, let's make a list of all these ones
because I've gotten the
one, now I know I got,
I got the one and I started
to try to make a list.
And I was like, I know
we wore combat boots.
And I started being like, oh my God,
I can't even remember his name.
I can't remember. Like,
and I was like, you didn't,
you didn't stop my progression,
but I was so devastated or so
I thought, cause I think I'd,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- I don't even know if I liked it. I mean,
I liked people plenty,
but I think it was more about
putting the pressure on myself
to be like,
everyone had to be the one or
the job had to be the thing.
And I'm like, what if it's just
- [Kelly Clarkson] The next step.
- It's a step because I can't
remember that guy's name
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- to save my life. And then I just had.
- Or your just like, why
did I date that person?
- Yeah.
- How lonely was I?
- What would I have told my friend,
if they would have like
been out with this guy
- Yeah exactly.
- This guy?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Instead I was like, well,
(laughing)
I wasn't like, I wasn't like a,
a wimpy person. I think it's just part of,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- kind of coming into yourself.
- I think, can you be
a strong people though?
Like, especially if you're so strong
in your passionate person,
you're a hundred percent into
something. So I get like,
yeah. Okay.
So you also wrote, "Just
eat the damn cookie".
(laughing)
Hi. Hey, I will tell you.
Recently I've stolen
Jesse and Jason's diet.
They call it the joy diet.
It's whatever brings you joy.
(laughing)
- I like that one
(clapping)
I like that one
- [Kelly Clarkson] It's like
Marie Kondo, but with food.
Cause you find yourself, honestly,
you find yourself going
well, do I really want it?
Like, and sometimes you don't,
but like when you really do you do it,
- I just think.
- Yeah, like what does the
cookie represent? Exactly.
- There's many cookies.
- Exactly.
It's also just about like,
I'm not going to make
myself feel bad anymore.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- I'm goona eat the damn pasta.
It's not even about the eating.
It's just like,
do what do the thing that
you love because you love it.
If it's not hurting you
or hurting anybody else,
- Yeah
- Some imaginary standard. I'm like,
if I don't eat the cookie,
I'm not going to wake up
six-two and modeling.
(laughing)
It's not gonna change, I'm
like, I'm okay where I am.
I'm not like, oh God, my
legs are fine. I have water.
It's like all the denying
and like do so much of like a
shouldn't. I just don't do it.
Don't do limit your coffee.
Maybe it should switch from
all milk, blah, blah, blah,
all that stuff. Now I'm
just like, I'm going to,
if it's not detrimental
to me or anyone else,
I'm just going to, I'm going
to have the damn cookie,
- [Kelly Clarkson] You know
what? we're going to end there.
(laughing)